we have to talk about something today
that is going to make some of the people
in our audience extremely uncomfortable
because it turns out that Donald Trump
disproportionately appealed to
cognitively challenged voters to voters
likely to perform poorly on intellectual
ability tests now I want to issue a
disclaimer here because I know I know
what's going to happen Pat we know what
the response will be if you are a
so-called race realist who wants to just
go where the evidence takes us if you're
in the facts don't care about your
feelings crowd if you're against
claiming to be offended
to shut down debate because being
offended isn't an argument I'm glad
you're here
because you then must allow the facts to
lead you where they may and they lead
down the path of Trump voter voters
being as a whole less intellectually
capable than Hillary Clinton supporters
on a totally standard test known as a
solid indicator of intellectual ability
this doesn't mean every Trump supporter
is dumb this doesn't mean that some
smart people don't support Donald Trump
it just means that in total in the
aggregate Donald Trump was
disproportionately supported by voters
with lesser intellectual ability and
more cognitive challenges than Hillary
Clinton
the research team was led by Joe of
Ganza of tel-aviv University now if
you're a race realist
you should really believe these results
because Jews supposedly are the smart
ones according to the race realists and
we've got a guy from Tel Aviv University
named you have gonzaque who's gonna give
us the results this is the most credible
source of information how can you argue
against that before the race real
absolutely the study analyzed data from
the American national election studies
report and it points out that quote
intellectual factors played an important
role in the 2016 election these results
suggest that the 2016 presidential
election u.s. presidential election had
less to do with party affiliation income
or education and more to do with basic
cognitive ability the subjects of the
study were given a basic verbal
abilities test with
is widely accepted as a pretty good
indicator of overall cognitive ability
and the Trump supporters were
under-equipped relative to Hillary
Clinton voters higher verbal ability
education cognitive ability were
associated with supporting Obama over
Romney in 2012 and with Hillary over
Trump in 2016 this is interesting on a
few levels first of all we were told
Trump won because of economic anxiety
the data now show that that was mostly
an empty explanation it wasn't a good
explanation however we do see evidence
that fear of losing social status as
well as racist and sexist beliefs were
positively correlated with support for
Donald Trump we also know that racism
and sexism are affiliated with lack of
intellectual capacity overall that's an
interesting data point we also have
another study unrelated to this one that
points similarly which says the
Democrats who chose to cross party lines
and vote for Trump were
disproportionately the ones who engaged
in lower levels of critical thinking
hello
another data point that suggests that
tel-aviv University study that the Tel
Aviv University study is on to something
so I'm ready for the hate mail
David you guys are never gonna win by
insulting Trump voters I'm telling you
this because it's apparently the reality
based on the facts we have the reality
doesn't care about how you feel about
these results what does it tell us about
winning elections though that's really
the question because we know that
playing off of people's basic
fear-driven instincts works really well
we've known that for a while people are
not going to make informed analyses they
are overwhelmingly going to react
instinctively that's not new there's
something called the dunning-kruger
effect I interviewed David Dunning about
it some years ago the dunning-kruger
effect references people who lack the
cognitive ability to understand why they
misunderstand something so the question
is what do we do we know that things are
never as simple as simpletons make them
seem we know that real life is complex
it's mostly clear at great gray area but
is that just a loser's path
look at John Kerry versus George Bush
for example I've put aside the potential
irregularities in Ohio during that
election do we play the game to win I
don't know the answer I I really don't
know the answer here and I want to hear
from you about it because I don't know
what we had a call about this last week
something along the lines of should
Democrats use the tactics of the right
to win in order the debt to then
actually do a progressive agenda or are
we quote stooping to their level if we
do that and you know if we don't start
winning things are gonna get way worse
so I think at a certain point from a
purely pragmatic perspective you've got
to say we need to start winning at least
using the tactics that we know work
today's show was made possible in part
by Scion Games and their new game for
phone and tablet called antidote which
is an award-winning strategy game it's
all about using vaccines to defend the
human body from bacteria and viruses
it's fast paced the graphics are amazing
the game has actually been commended by
the World Health Organization because it
has a mission to fight back against the
anti vaccine misinformation so the game
is educational and fun to play download
antidote for free on your phone or
tablet in the Google Play Store or the
iOS App Store and have a blast using
vaccines and the body's immune system to
fight off deadly diseases and don't
forget to search for scion games on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram if you're
watching this on YouTube I've put the
links under the video